terrain un homme également n'a forcément
pas laisser passer cette joie immense
qui était la sienne il s'agit d'aimé
jacquet le sélectionneur
à mon avis il s'est fait beaucoup de
soucis pendant le match ce soir il est
soulagé nous l'écoutons dominique
champeaux a réussi à le rencontrer juste
à la sortie
ace du match c'est une belle
qualification elle est à mon avis mérité
par le jeu que nous avons déployés
surtout dans la dans la phase je dirais
du match où l'équipe de france a été
extrêmement conquérante
malheureusement on n'a pas su
concrétiser toutes nos belles situations
offensives
on a vu une équipe de france en première
mi-temps très maîtresse d'elle-même
frais maîtresses dresseur sujet fort
très dominatrice en deuxième mi temps ça
a commencé un petit peu la fatigue
commence à se faire sentir non c'est
surtout que lorsqu'on change le
dispositif
on s'est un petit peu affaibli tout à
fait normalement mais il faut les bien
faire quelque chose moi je ne voulais
pas arriver à aux prolongations donc
encore moins au coup de pied au but
la décision s'est pas trop mal tourné
pour nous heureusement on vous a vu
beaucoup moins expansif que contre le
paraguay
non parce que là dans 1 dans un match ce
type là nous savons les forces qui est
qu'ils sont contre nous et là il faut
être toujours en réflexion pour apporter
quelques petites retouches à l'équipe
pour lui donner une bouffée d'oxygène
donc il faut rester lucide contre le
paraguay on a écrasé c'est l'équipe donc
c'était parce que je dirais une
injustice que le voir que cette équipe
de france est pas marqué de but la combi
équipe italienne il faut faire très
attention ce sont des maîtres dans et
qui sont qui sont des maîtres dans l'art
de prendre en contre
je sais que c'est un match que vous
tenez absolument à gagner parce que
c'était le match de référence pour cette
équipe
ou oui mais on a bien fait dans son
contenu je pense que la qualification
s'est faite aux coups de pied au but
mais elle aurait pu se faire normalement
tard par un but ou par une situation
beaucoup plus favorable pour l'équipe de
france on peut dire ce soir sur ce qu'on
a vu de ce match que l'équipe de france
peut aller au bout
les allées au bout mais valéo bout c'est
obligé tellement qu'il y ait de la foi
non c'est dans cette équipe il ya un
groupe qui qui est fabuleux qui a envie
de réussir quelque chose l'a vu encore
même dans les prolongations où on a eu
cette équipe de france qui tentait tout
qu'ils essayaient de bousculer cette
cette défense de fer italienne merci
aimé jacquet l'équipe de france
reprendra
tout de suite la route de clairefontaine
ou quatre jours ne seront pas de trop
pour préparer ces demi finales que l'on
attend évidemment avec impatience